hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the 1958
interzoneal on the white end Bobby
Fischer and he's paired against bent
Larson
opening Wise It's in open Sicilian
we have the dragon variation
and I believe the main issue with
Larson's play is that he
underestimated the value of Fisher's
King Bishop
on this move nine it's deployed to C4
it functions very well in this diagonal
opposite the king
the pawn is pinned
it's this bishop that's the star piece
in the game it's a both sides of the
ball peace plays an offensive role
defensive role and as we will soon see
acts as a great Catalyst for an attack
against the black king side
play follows with Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight Bishop E6 Bishop B3
White's prepared to follow the general
rule in this case
taking towards the center on B3 if black
captures there
however that mentality changes in a
couple moves Queen A5 Queen side castles
so now
white would not be taking with the a
pawn
because white would be moving in the
wrong direction
backwards
instead
if Bishop takes B3 you'd be taken with
the c Pawn throwing the King on the B
file and
probably fighting
along the newly opened C file shortly
thereafter
okay there is no Bishop takes B3 in this
game
instead B5
standard move now after Queen side
castles
King B1
once more after Bishop takes B3 even
though there's
there would be no Queen A1 if White's
taking towards the center
best is to con to capture with the c
pawn and again prepare to fight along
the C file
in the game it's B4 Knight's given a
kick to the center
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop
and we reach a very important moment in
the game
The Rook is hit
how to react exactly
this next move is considered in
inaccuracy in the computer's eyes
um it's really the main the main issue
let's say in the game
when I shared the tale of tape
inaccuracies mistakes blunders again it
registers as an inaccuracy this is the
this is really the big big problem in
the game
this guy now lives gets to go back to B3
and
from there it's an amazing piece
now what may be kept Larson from
capturing the bishop I'm not sure
exactly
uh it could be that he
this is kind of tough to say but he may
have overestimated
his own King Bishop
and it's I'm saying it's tough to say
that because this is in its own right a
super important piece an important
Defender for your own kingside
but there is a good
continuation after Knight takes Bishop
if white is knocking out the bishop like
this
black can follow with Knight to C3 and
we basically get into a rook specific
ending where
white is up a pawn but it's
it cannot be seen as a full pawn and
there's really no hope to play for a win
so let me share this variation with you
this position right here white is in
fact up a pawn but it's a half dead Pawn
a lot of weaknesses here how do you how
do you even defend this isn't really
this wouldn't be a fun way to try and
babysit the pawns if you're trying to
defend with the King
well first of all
could be given a kick
it tried to defend like this but then
black could remind you that you have
another weak Pawn
it's really no hope
to press for win here as white
so this would have been the best try for
black now to go straight into that Rook
specific ending but instead Rook a to C8
the light Square Bishop lives
from here Rook C7
and the next move by black is Queen to
B5 looking to next
you know free the pawn to bother the
bishop
this is a time sensitive position we
have
you know this is the case because the
kings are on opposite sides of the board
I think also what factors in is
the fact that the Queens are still
present and they're still
some aggressive Intentions by both sides
it's a race position so one slip and
you know it could be over for you
Rook C7
an important move to First defend the
pawn if you're trying to quickly go in
for Queen B5 with the idea to run the a
pawn down
white would be able to
knock out the a pawn now at first glance
some may say that's crazy you've just
opened up a new file and there might be
something happening here but hang on
that most valuable piece
is around to defend A2 if that happens
so
it's not just here defending C2 but also
A2
great great piece
Rook C7 babysit the a pawn first
foreign
with H4
Fisher one of his quotes being
you know his concise his blueprint for
dismantling the Sicilian Dragon it's
quoted as saying pry open the H file
sack sack and mate we do get to see a
sacrifice in this game
okay from here it's Queen B5
H5
black ignores it carries on with forming
a battery on the C file
let me highlight A variation to
demonstrate just how powerful this guy
is this is one of the many variations
where this guy shines
if Knight takes H5
there would be Bishop takes Bishop
if Knight takes Bishop the queen sneaks
in here how do you stop the threat there
you have to play Knight H5 and then
you're scared away with G4
some other try King takes Bishop well G4
still
Queen slips in G5 hits
Chop on H5 G6 the pawn is pinned
Pawn takes and here's one cool way this
game could go straight to check
and mate
okay
one other line pretty crazy if you're
taking like this there would be G4 takes
and quick pop quiz which one of White's
pieces is not attacking the black king
okay
don't think too hard
all of them are attacking none of the
above
we could have some fun here drawing
lines this is not survivable
okay from here battery is formed H file
is pried open
g-pawn ready to scare the Knight it's a
race
g4a5 G5 whites hitting first there is
still hope
for black to survive this but you have
to be super precise
and that Precision is not found after
Rook takes Knight black recaptures and
it's winning from this point on for
white
there is one way to save it and that is
to initiate this exchange on D4 which
at first glance seems very
counterintuitive why are we doing this
isn't white able to recapture and
improve the queen isn't she better
placed on D4 rather than D2 cutting
right into the the dark squares on the
king side
let's have a look at this variation
what is the idea exactly
well after Queen takes Bishop Pawn takes
in G6
white uh black and play this move Rook
to C4
and after Pawn takes you'll notice the G
file is now opened the king gets to
recapture
and stay off of the G file now the king
will not be forced onto the G file
what am I talking about exactly well if
there was still tension between the
Bishops
white would be able to
follow up with after G takes F7 there
could be Bishop takes bishop and then
the king would be pulled to the G file
which is Paving the way for white to
insert a very useful Rook reposition
getting to the G file with check
what am I talking about exactly well let
me compare this let's say we go with the
move played in the game
and then after this move
only now let's say we have the move
Rook to G4 excuse me Rook to C4
now we could take
after King takes you'll notice white
gets to initiate the exchange and pull
the king to a much more vulnerable
Square
follow up with Rook G1
Etc Queen H6 maybe Queen to G2
this is completely winning for team
white it's already reading a mate
okay so this was the only way for black
to survive to flick in this capture
first but doesn't find it
instead the more human move to
immediately recapture on H5 now comes G6
white is there first that pawn is pinned
black tries to shut things down some
with E5 Pawn takes would check
King f8 Bishop E3 and now this is a cool
cool Try by Larson with D5
trying to interfere with
the bishop
the the major pieces there are a couple
ways to go wrong is white
in
taking with the bishop and queen are
both wrong ways
taking with the queen black is happy
that the Queens are going to be off and
you could maybe hope to still survive
this
if you're taking with the bishop there's
Rook takes C2
okay Fischer follows with
uh the winning way let's say takes with
the pawn at the moment this guy is
masked
but that is short-lived
play follows with Rook takes F7 and The
Bishop's eyes are
uh opened back up
now if some other move is tried in this
position let's say with A4
white would be able to play D6 and
the bishop if the Bishops capture The
Rook is captured and nothing's nothing
exciting is happening on A2 or C2 the
timing is just not right for black
so what is trade is Rook takes F7 D6
Rook is hit
goes to F6 keeping an eye on the D6
Square
if you're taking the pawn
there's D7 how do you stop promotion
Rook d
well there's Queen D6
and that's me
okay so the try here is Rook F6
watching over D6
Bishop G5
Queen B7 and
what else to try oh there's there's one
other variation I want to highlight here
this is a cool one
in this position here instead of Rook
takes Pawn
after A4 and D6
I tested out this one I thought to
myself what are we doing exactly
if the Rook goes to C6
there would be Bishop to E6 in this
position
this is really neat Bishop E6 in this
case black can allow
the C2 Pawn to be captured
after Rook takes C2 there would be
Bishop to G5 and that is very pretty
you could allow the queen to be captured
because the Bishops are enough along
with the pawns to deliver me
it's a pretty variation
okay in the game it is Rook takes Pawn
D6
Rook F6 Bishop G5 Queen B7
white grabs The Rook
and now with D7 cuts the Queen off from
defending any
of the king side squares
any of Black's King side squares
after Rook to d8 one final move
Queen D6 and black resigns
what do you do here
if you play King to G7
Rook G1
Etc
I'm gonna be taking the bishop next
and let's say if Bishop to E7 that's a
quick mate
the piece is crisscrossing there along
the diagonal
and one fun note this is actually not
the uh that's not actually the fastest
way to mate
this is considered even better
Queen to H6
and if you block with the bishop we have
mate in this way
adjacent diagonals for me
and if you move the king to E7 it's
check and Checkmate once again
highlighting the strength of this light
Square Bishop knifing in towards the
king
okay however you slice it Queen D6 Queen
H6 all roads are leading to Checkmate
eventually
okay anyhow let's have a look at the
tail of the tape on this one we could
see
the inaccuracies mistakes and blunders
for each side the accuracy for Fisher 95
87 for Larson
and just highlighting the the
inaccuracies
mistakes for Larson
it's really the inaccuracies what's
considered inaccuracy G6 okay we could
hardly consider G6 and inaccuracy it's
really this decision right here Rook a
to C8 allowing that
star piece in the game Fisher's King
Bishop
to remain on board great offensive
defensive piece
great Catalyst for an attack in this
particular game
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye